this is such a great time in sports you
have a new masters champion the nba
player is about to start baseball's in
the full swing
people getting engaged i mean it's a
happy time in the world it's crazy
alex rodriguez reacts to his ex-fiance
jennifer lopez getting engaged to ben
affleck it's gracie
uh happiness and the world peace is what
we're looking for yeah it all went down
during a live broadcast on espn2 when
the former athlete's co-host michael k
subtly brings up benefer's exciting news
this is such a great time in sports you
have a new masters champion the nba
player is about to start baseball's in
the full swing
people getting engaged i mean it's a
happy time in the world it's crazy
now you'll remember j.lo and a-rod have
a long history together
the two first met in 1999 but it wasn't
until 2017 that they turned their
friendship into a full-blown romance i
mean we've been having a lot of fun and
i've been enjoying just spending time
with her our kids her kids
fast forward two years to 2019 and the
pair got engaged but by april 2021 they
called it quits whatever's happened to
me over the last year i'm so grateful
for it i mean i had uh five years of of
an incredible
life in in partnership and also with my
daughters we learned so much and now we
have an opportunity to take that and
move forward and say you know what we're
so grateful for the last five years and
just a few weeks later jlo rekindled her
romance with ben after the pair was
previously engaged from 2002 to 2004 and
the rest is kind of history
is engaged again which leads us back to
her former fiance's reaction to the big
news it's crazy
happiness and the world peace is what
we're looking for
feeling so lucky it's not often you get
a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky
i love you
i love you too it's true second time's a
charm for the couple and since
announcing their engagement jen's been
sharing more details about the intimate
proposal it was totally unexpected
my love came in ben came in and he got
down on one knee
and he said some things that i'll never
forget
and then he pulled out a ring
and he said will you marry me
and it was
the most perfect moment
and he hands me a ring
and he said it's a green diamond
my favorite color it's also my lucky
color
and turns out the couple's kids love the
new rock she's got
[Music]
a source tells e.t the kids are all very
excited and have been telling her how
pretty and huge the ring is yeah i'm
ready i'm excited about it our source
adds quote jen definitely wants a
wedding and wants to share the moment in
a bigger way she loves the idea of
marrying the love of her life and then
partying after with their family and
friends
ben had been telling his friends he was
going to propose for a while so no one
was surprised
[Music]
[Music]
you